hello and welcome to the nerdwriter
podcast movie review edition this is the
first podcast that I'm attempting to do
I love podcasts I love listening to them
I just think there's something special
about them I love audio I love really
great audio I love listening to the
human voice when it's nice clothes nice
and close to a really good mic so I'm
gonna try a podcast here I just got out
of the movie looper and I want to talk
about that today I'm not going to do
percentages you can do Rotten Tomatoes
for that not gonna do stars who knew
Roger Ebert for that I just want to talk
about the movie and I think that I do
have the qualifications to talk about
movies because I was a film student I
know a little bit about what goes into
making a movie
I've tried writing short films I even
tried getting my hand trying to do a
feature a couple years ago didn't work
out but I at least know what it takes so
I have all that much more respect for
Rian Johnson the director of looper and
writer who composed this time travel
story oh and I want to mention before I
start I haven't read anything about this
I haven't seen any reviews haven't read
any reviews I don't know what Rotten
Tomatoes even gave it which is strange
for me I usually always check before I
go I know what some friends have said
and the reviews have been in the all in
the range of good some really good some
great some lukewarm but still mostly
positive so I really enjoyed it I had a
great time watching the movie the
experience of watching it was a lot of
fun the first the first half hour to an
hour of the movie I thought was just
flawless storytelling really quick
getting all the information out there
that you need the world that they're
living in 2044 is explained in the
process of the story future movies that
are said in the future can sometimes get
caught up in explaining the world that
they're living in and I don't think that
looper falls into that trap I think that
the elements of the future the future
technologies that you're shown the way
that the world is are done as
sort of a side-glance to the story
proper and I think that the world is
very interesting there's a few sort of
technological changes that you see
things that you might expect nothing too
ridiculous but also you get the sense
that it this is a dystopian future the
2044 of this world is something is going
wrong in the period of time in between
maybe something not terrible has gone
wrong they may they make one reference
to the vagrant raids of the
something-something so government or the
ability to police whatever city that
this story is said in a sort of broken
down a little bit
seems like the crime bosses have control
of the town people are getting shot you
know out near buses for whatever reason
because you know they're trying to steal
something so it's not a place that you'd
maybe want to live unless that is you
were a looper and I think that the
character of the looper is very
interesting and I'm realizing things as
I as I just thinking about this movie
having seen it which i think is gonna
happen in the next couple days which I
which is the mark of a good movie one of
the things is that these loopers are
people who are not really thinking about
their future right they go to the same
bar every day they get paid for their
job killing people from the future and
they're doing the same drugs you know
when I was for the for those of us who
went to college I used to call this the
haze you just do the same things over
and over again and it felt like frankly
a loop right the same night the same
weekend over and over again you lose
track of time you lose track of yourself
I think that is something that the
loopers in this movie are definitely
going through symbolized by the fact
that one of the key elements is
something called closing the loop where
the bosses in the future have somehow
deemed it cleaning their own hands of
loose ends
they've sent back these kids loopers
when they're old or thirty years in the
future to kill themselves you don't know
that it's gonna be them because they're
you know bagged on the head but these
kids these loopers don't they really
don't have a future
thirty years and that's it so there's a
layer there there's a subtext there of
are these people's lives anything more
than what they do the montage in the
beginning does a lot of that for you and
the the way that the drug for example
this drop in your eye is filmed it's
just really really stylistic and smart
and I think that is something that is
shown throughout the whole movie but
moving on oh and I probably should
mention there's going to be spoilers in
this so if you haven't seen it I'd say
stop listening right now and go out and
see it it is worth your money to see so
things start to get a little bit more
intense more serious when Joseph
gordon-levitt's character played by
Bruce Willis his future self comes back
to the past and they show in a montage
of the years intervening what happens to
him it goes to China does some more
killing but then he eventually falls in
love with this Asian woman who he says
saves him saves him from this life now
there's potentially troubling thing in
this to begin with which is the fact
that Joseph Erwin Levitt is a murderer
he's murdered people who he doesn't know
that they've done something bad even if
we decided that murdering people was
okay it doesn't know that it doesn't
mean bad he's just taking the he's
taking the word of the bosses in the
future that they want them dead so he
doesn't really sit so it's hard already
to sympathize with him in the beginning
that will become much much harder for
the Bruce Willis character later in the
movie but we'll get to that the main
criticism I have with time travel movies
in this movie is that depending on what
the movie is you can sort of get a sense
you get the feeling towards the end that
the movie is trying to figure itself out
time travel movies are so much about the
writing of them is so much about closing
all the loop the loose ends making sure
that it's logical that it works right
especially ones that are explicitly
about time travel like looper now of
course you can't close out every loose
end with time talking movies we always
take things for granted for example we
know that it's not logical that only
small things would change for the future
Bruce Willis when little things change
in the present of the movie when he cuts
his arm we know that little moments in
the future affect big consequences or
little moments in the present effect big
consequences in the future the the the
butterfly effect the KSR effect so all
of these things being at the being at
that bar to meet that asian woman who
eventually marries those things don't
happen after us a little thing like just
a small misstep in the in another
direction happens but we let those
things go in time travel movies because
if we didn't we wouldn't be able to have
time-travel movies it just wouldn't work
right back to the future a great time
travel movie the the picture
disappearing thing is you know when when
when their existence becomes
questionable they disappear in the
picture that is ridiculous but because
it's like it goes from the head goes
from the head down to the to the feet
the last thing that they get it's just
ridiculous but we let it go because we
know that some liberties have to be
taken and and that's it's a good example
that these two movies are good are good
to compare against each other because
the time-travel elements in back to the
future are very campy to begin with and
it's a very campy moving and back to the
future spends a lot of time on the
character and the story in the past of
Marty and the parents and all that stuff
even though time-travel is the rapping
that is all around it looper is one of
these movies in the line of Inception
Dark Knight the Chris Nolan type of
movies where everything has to be sort
of airtight watertight right this is
really realistic this is what would
happen this is how it would be my main
criticism of looper and in that vein is
that you feel at the end of the movie
the time-travel elements of the story
spinning themselves to their proper
conclusion and that for me takes away
from the character development which
which for a great movie is always always
the center of the story not to say there
aren't great characters in this movie I
think that Joseph gordon-levitt Bruce
Willis and Emily Blunt do great acting
jobs for their characters but there are
a few things that sort of go wonky in
the third act first when Bruce Willis
kills that kid whatever sympathy you had
for him immediately goes away we know
from Rian Johnson the directors choice
early on that the fact that he doesn't
show LME emily Blunt's child's face the
first three times we see him we know
that he's the Rainmaker that that's
something that I don't think he's trying
to hide from us and the fact that we
know that means that the first kid that
Bruce Willis kills is an innocent child
and even though he feels remorse about
it afterwards it's hard for us to
sympathize with Bruce Willis again I
don't know if that's Ryan well Ryan or
Ryan Johnson's intention for us
sympathize but we don't do it after that
excuse me taking a drink here and then
we have that almost what essentially is
Bruce Willis becomes John McClane from
die hard and starts ripping people apart
with machine guns and semi-automatic
guns just killing scores and scores of
people this guy is lost to our
empathetic urges right he can't get what
he wants you cannot build a love so
strong to justify for the viewer the
murder that he commits in the end of
that movie and and I like I said before
it's already hard with Joseph
gordon-levitt character oh and one thing
by the way that I mentioned that I had
noticed that I don't think the person
was watching it with notice which I
thought was an interesting little thing
so the punk kid who's got the gat who
really shouldn't be allowed to have any
kind of gun because he is ridiculous
that's Jeff Daniels from the future from
from the present
that's Jeff Daniels past self I think
the way that you can tell the way that I
noticed it was when Jeff Daniels died
and he's sort of looking at him
really sad the next thing he sees on the
wall is the map where Joseph
gordon-levitt is and there's a circle on
the map and I think that is supposed to
symbolize closing the loop so well done
Ryan Johnson on that that's that was a
good little moment I think I'm right
about that I could be wrong so when
Joseph gordon-levitt kills himself in
the end and is able to change the
rainmakers future to be Kazuma bleah
he's gonna become good now whatever him
the process the the the the moment of
him killing himself to me felt
unsatisfying the reason was because I
felt the time-travel elements
overshadowing the character elements
there had to be an end
to this story that worked for a a fallen
character like Jeff so gordon-levitt
killing yourself is really the only way
to go first of all so you already have
that second of all what happens you know
Bruce Willis cannot be made to get back
with the Asian woman his wife Jo Sakura
Levitt isn't going to go on to live with
Emily Blunt and the kid right so this is
really the only ending of the movie that
there could be and there are a lot of
really great movies I should mention
that have fallen characters lowlife
characters but it's broadcast very early
on about those characters that they
won't make it and you know it a good
distance from the end the fact that Rian
Johnson tries to keep up his suspense
like maybe Joseph gordon-levitt might
make it I think actually takes away from
the movie because it would be a sort of
I think it just would be an empty
feeling if he got to live I think that's
the trap the movie gets into it would be
an empty feeling for the viewer if he
got to live it's hard to redeem that
kind of character but he didn't make him
a tragic character early early enough in
the movie so you're sort of vacillating
between the two sides will he make it
well that's not gonna feel great
but he's not telling me that he's not
gonna make it so that's really my main
criticism of the movie is that the
characters are subsumed by the plot
elements of making a time travel story
work all that said really really
enjoyable movie I mean one thing that
was fantastic sound editing sound mixing
Wow amazing I don't know who did it but
you did a great job and you should be
nominated for an Oscar because I thought
that the way that the story moved along
with sound wasn't brilliant and despite
the problems I had with the end of it it
just that that really just precludes it
from becoming a great movie from a
really really good movie so I think that
if you haven't seen it which would be
ridiculous at this point because I've
spoiled all of it but if you haven't go
see it it's worth the money to go see
that's the review I have a looper I hope
you enjoyed it hope it wasn't too long
and if you want you you know leave
please leave in comments what you think
about this if you want me to do more of
them it's a lot of fun and I will see
you next time